hi I'm Kevin since mon with GQ magazine
and we're in the Sierra Nevada mountains
with the 2009 Nissan GTR the exterior of
the GTR is all about aerodynamics
everything from the air intake here and
then you have these indentations here
which help air flow around the car you
have these bullet shaped intakes on the
hood there this sculpted front fender
here it helps air flow nissan calls
these aero blades and that increases
airflow but it also helps ventilate the
brakes on these 20 inch wheels this
little kink and the c-pillar that helps
air flow over the top and through this
functional spoiler here this isn't
decoration another nice little touch
this black part on the mirror it helps
decrease wind noise so that when you're
going 120 miles per hour which you can
and we have you can actually have a
conversation one of my favorite details
about the car is the recessed door
handle makes the car more aerodynamic
but it's just a cool feature now let's
take a look at the interior you have
transmission settings suspension
settings and traction settings to vary
the comfort level you can put it all on
and race and that's when you're showing
off with your friends or you can put
this on comfort and that's when you've
got grandma in the passenger seat and
you're going out to Sunday brunch if
this screen looks like a screen on a
video game you want to be too far off it
was actually designed by the people who
designed gran turismo gives you a bunch
of super geeky data what the car is
really about though is this
a twin-turbo 3.8 liter v6 that generates
480 horsepower and 430 pound-feet of
torque the power that it generates just
feels limitless alright now let's take
this thing for a spin and hope I don't
get any tickets
this really is a supercar that you're
meant to drive every day but when you
really want to let it rip he's put into
manual shift gears here or you can shift
gears up here which is actually
preferable and just down shift and just
let er rip the four-wheel drive offers
great stability in the rain in the snow
and also when you decide to take a
corner at 90 miles per hour so let's go
do track and really see what this thing
can do here we are at the Reno currently
Raceway in fernley nevada and we're
about to take a lap with a GTR on the
racetrack hopefully I won't die all
right get in all right let's do it
and we're off whoa there we go
fishtailing
alright this is the tricky part you
can't really see the road coming all
right wait a minute
oh yeah that feels good oh no that was
fun yeah it's you ended with your right
blinker yes always use your traffic
signals
you